[Applaudissements]
bertrand c'est pas dans mes habitudes
mais je tenais vraiment vous féliciter
maman moment au prix de meilleur
chroniqueur de la tnt c'est très gentil
fabrice allouche non pas pour ça pour
votre chronique d'hier c'était de loin
la meilleure depuis trois ans vraiment
enfin fabrice j'ai pas fait crever
clergé pas pu placer une seule image à
cause des invités oui mais justement
c'était votre mail chronique depuis
trois ans c'est la chronique non les
malades on a reçu symbion une plainte
contre cyril hanouna pour plagiat qui
l'attaquent alors les élèves de ce2 de
l'école pierre bachelet donnant à gaza
qu alors ils accusent le paquet de faire
de l'audience sur leur dos un il aurait
pompé le cache-cache le chat perché et
la courte paille
bref il est mal je vois je vois pas
comment il peut s'en sortir on va
arriver à un coût et bonbons fabrice ya
un truc qui m'angoisse
il nous reste dix huit émissions pour
arriver à notre but ça fait trois mois
qu'on patauge
je tends de chances de récupérer la
place de no naku tombé sur une photo de
passe muraille de fort boyard déguisé en
miss france info m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
photomontage ça non je sais
malheureusement il s'agit de la personne
[Musique]
quel carton pour des 8,5 trophée en or
je me demande ce qu'ils vont en faire
écouter mon bon fabrice j'ai eus ar
africaine ce média au téléphone ils vont
envoyer toute sa chaire postale pour un
échange sur poster oui là c'est de l'or
contre de l'argent
et toute cette une ça leur fait au moins
trois saisons d'inspecteur barnaby pour
l'année prochaine
malin le oui oui je lui demande je vis
de mon chum on sait qui c'est le pack
imac et steve et encore celui-ci
ils demandent si vous êtes bien les
livres et le maalox à l'elysée françois
hollande a bien sûr on donne une mission
de la rampe y est on a envoyé notre mire
jean patrick patrick oui bah le seul
agent qu'on avait bonjour monsieur
les livraisons c'est par ici livraison
pour vous conviendrait du maroc pour
france soir
c'est un petit cadeau accepté le maalox
c'est pour les problèmes de digestion
vous allez vous lui donnez pas de notre
part regardez on officie à tous il ya de
l'eau et a juste lâché
ce qu'il faut c'est un petit cadeau
c'est du maroc
soyez sympa pour l'épreuve de digestion
comme ça pendant ses discours il sera
bien capa qui doit être transmis à
l'elysée
il doit être transmis ce scellé avec le
nom de la personne à qui était adressé
et il faut que vous ayez une pièce
d'identité
voilà vous savez ce qu'il vous reste à
faire lundi le problème c'est qu'on a du
matériel de pignoufs ils nous ont crié
en deux et ils regardent touche pas à
mon poste
elle malheureusement j'ai perçu sais pas
mais je sais mais je veux lui donner
c'est du maroc c'est pour lui c'est pour
la france en plus là mais y'a pas que
les micros aussi je repère l'afp cameron
non mais pas les salaires qu'ils
allaient arrêter vous allez arrêtez
votre cinéma on vous l'a déjà expliqué
on écoute et le retour des chroniqueurs
au sujet de notre intervention là bas
voilà on est des personnalités on
attendait des personnes voilà mais c'est
du jamais vu
de l'humour armes et ennemis au décor
prénom bon bah du coup qu'est ce qu'on
vit jour président frérot
[Applaudissements]
fabrice c'est le grand jour ça faisait
un petit moment déjà sous le coup d'une
menace plus beaucoup de temps donc je
dégaine la preuve c'est tout chaud ça
sort de l'imprimerie les mains bertrand
chamerois la face cachée du pakistanais
300 pages de révélations sulfureuses à
propos de l'animateur le plus con retenu
par fait je peux vous dire que ces
bombes sur bomble avec ce que je mets
dans la tronche il se relève après ça
génial et vous avez trouvé un éditeur
pour ça voilà j'ai passé un coup de fil
un ami ce week end un certain yves derai
l'internât biographie non autorisée et
elle m'a dit oui tout de suite sans dire
le truc il a même écrit cinq six pages
en plus tout ce que vous avez toujours
voulu savoir sur cette raclure sans oser
le demander
ouais c'est fort c'est faux s'est formé
bertrand si vous sortez ça vous allez
vous faire virer deux des huit toujours
aux avant-postes tout ça ne vous n'allez
pas prendre sa place quoi j'avais pas
pensé à ça
j'avais pas concerts sont exactes et
puis la face cachée on la connaît déjà
quoi commença à huy lê kha tiers de jean
luc lemoine c6 il est d'ores et déjà ça
bon nous reste combien de temps
concrètement il nous reste onze jours